bring in Lane Kiffin the head coach at
Florida Atlantic and he joins us
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
coach what did you see last night really
an amazing game you know the first
quarter was probably what would've
guessed was going to happen and kind of
happen you know except for the red zone
in the game that it was back and forth
and just explosive offensive players
great receivers you know I can't imagine
a championship game with better
receivers skilled players on both sides
offensively and then all of a sudden the
turnovers and the inability in the red
zone
you know the fake field goal couple fork
down stops and you know all sudden the
game you know was was totally one-sided
at that point when did you know Alabama
was in trouble I'm at the end of the
first half
you know when they sat on the ball there
you know it was an aggressive game plan
by cooks David and he was going forward
in his own territory which is very
unusual for him and and when they sat on
the ball with whatever was 30 seconds
left and all of em all our timeouts I
was kind of I was kind of reward it was
going the other way if you were still
the offensive coordinator knowing what
you know after watching the game what
would you have done differently oh I
mean that's easy to say now obviously
you know it's going easy to say you know
would it have run the ball more because
you know the running backs in the line
we're still effective on all the outside
but that's easy to say now to came in as
a you know playing one of the greatest
games ever you know just to you know the
week before when we think three two or
three incompletions so that's easy to
say now but I think anybody'd say that
you know the day I asked her well
watching it last night I just kept
saying you're running the ball well why
not continue to do that because you know
there there's depth issues on Clemson's
line because his suspension so I just
would have kept him out there as long as
I could I know two is great but in the
moment I kept thinking whenever they
wanted to run they could run the
football could you have talked Coach
Saban out of something if you were there
on the sidelines in the moment
well I don't think coaches ever on the
headset see and throw the ball so you
don't Victoria that wasn't going on I'm
sure that wasn't hot oh yeah you know
he's he always likes to run the ball and
control the clock and that's well
document it you know especially when his
defense is struggling in a game like
that you don't want to go three and out
and you know after 15 seconds to be back
out there so but you can't fault
offensive coaches and you've got some
great receivers great quarterback you
know that had done unbelievable things
set all the records and you know but
sitting there watching it which it's
always easier to watch and is you know
when you're in the moment calling those
plays you don't see it you know as well
especially if you have to be on the
sidelines so watching it yes that was
the feeling that they were not stopping
the run and you know that three-headed
monster three running backs they were
always fresh and and you know all three
guys are in SL running backs and Josh
Jacobs was unstoppable you know I'm in
short yardage and so it's easy to
second-guess and all that and say okay
what red zone why did she go Wildcat you
know because they didn't stop Wildcat
all day with Josh but you know that's
that's why your guys job is easy
who's if I said you could have a draft
pick you could take a two or Trevor
Lawrence NFL what would you take well
probably for the NFL Trevor but I'd be
hard-pressed not to take two over
college because of the because of the
rules and more rpoS now it is
transitioning as you're seeing the NFL
you know when you got some some shorter
guys doing good things but you know NFL
is you know or that arm release is in
his height and his ability and we're
talking about a young kid I just kept
watching him saying I'm waiting for them
to say hey this is Peyton Manning you
know because that that's who he looks
like
Wow when's when did he first come onto
your radar screen Trevor Lawrence I
think if I was trying to think this
morning I want to say maybe eighth grade
I believe he was in our he was in our
Alabama camp I think in like eighth
grade
right and which is just all he was
already really tall and you know we had
him up with like the juniors and seniors
and he look like he blogged you know and
then they're like yeah he's like 14
years old or something what is Nick
Saban doing today 730 staffing and and
he's he is on the recruiting which
starts Friday and obviously he's not
very happy today and but um you know
he'll turn the page and and he'll get on
to try to go sign the best recruiting
class in the country this would be a
wrong day to I show up late for that
7:30 meeting I'm gonna guess that I
would not go over well
7:13 starting about 7 o'clock I was also
curious your thoughts with what's
happened at USC with Kliff Kingsbury
pursuing head coaching jobs and he just
accepted the offensive coordinator
position what do you make of this
situation why it's highly unusual
obviously you know just getting fired
from college and going to take Courtney
job and then I don't think he has enough
no experience and you know interviewing
for those and so it is what it is I
didn't really follow I didn't somebody
said about them block I don't know
they must have written the contracts you
know very specific to that because
that's that's not normal college can't
block people you not saying that's all
things so they must have written those
contracts I'm special for that yeah I
think that he's now able to interview
and Winston Lynn Swann is not blocking
him from doing it but I I get the
feeling that once you start interviewing
you know you wait us he's gonna move on
it feels like USC they don't have any
leverage they they need
Kliff Kingsbury they need somebody like
that a bright offensive mind to help
that program but I I was surprised that
he took the job so quickly lane because
it feels like you could have had an
offensive coordinator job or maybe a
head coaching job in the NFL because
we're always looking for that next Sean
McVeigh and it feels like that's Kliff
Kingsbury yeah I think there's some
similarities there now Sean's in the NFL
you know that's an easier transition
so but that is just psyching you know
once something works now it's you know
let's find the young offensive energetic
guy you know that that spreads it around
and uses emotions and things so I can
definitely see you know where that's at
and why that's happening
well it's good to visit with you as
always and hope the program rebound
hopeless hope my Al's do better next
season after five and seven here
we'll be back Dan ory okay well thank
you coach so alright have a good on Lane
Kiffin Florida Atlantic head coach and
joining us in the countenance on Coach's
Corner Continental Tire no matter what
you drive where you drive how you drive
they have a tire for you for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]